hey 42 here in november 1922
howard carter came up on the final
resting place
of a little-known egyptian pharaoh known
as tooting car moon
when carter carefully removed the outer
door and stepped over the threshold
he became the first human being to do so
in well over 3 000 years
though carter didn't know it at the time
tooting car moon's tomb
was to become one of the greatest
archaeological finds
in the history of mankind right up there
with the terracotta army
the remains of pompeii and the rosetta
stone
news of the incredible discovery hit the
headlines
as the attention of the world's media
trained itself squarely on the valley of
the kings in egypt
near to what was once thebes it was the
crowning achievement of carter's career
something that would see him
immortalized amongst archaeologists
but from the moment he first stepped
inside the pharaoh's tomb
rumors began to spread that his actions
had unleashed a terrible curse
punishment from beyond the grave that
would be dished out to all of those who
had there to disturb
the long dead pharaoh plenty of people
thought it was nonsense
including carter himself but then
quite suddenly people started dying
a few months before this remarkable
moment in the history of archaeology
howard carter found himself standing in
downton abbey
well sort of the grand manor house was
actually called
high clear castle and it was home to the
fifth earl of carnarvon
rather than the seventh earl of grantham
but 88 years later it will be selected
to serve as the home of the fictional
crawley family
in everyone's favorite period drama
which is actually pretty apt
because as it happened carter found
himself at the center
of his own little drama that day in
1922.
you see the fifth earl of carnarvon was
his benefactor
the man who'd been financing carter's
archaeological expeditions
in the valley of the kings for the
previous seven years
during which time carter had turned up
next to nothing of archaeological
interest
admittedly the outbreak of the first
world war had somewhat hampered his
efforts
but that didn't change the fact that
carnavan had invested a lot of time and
money into the venture
in return for diddly squat
well i say diddly squat carter's years
in egypt
had yielded a few odds and ends scraps
of linen
and shards of pottery mostly it wasn't
much but many of these items shared
something strange in common
they were inscribed with a single word
the name of an egyptian pharaoh whose
remains
had never been located tutankhamun
you don't need the powers of a pharaoh
to preserve your hair
and keep it healthy all you need is
keeps
who've kindly sponsored this video i've
had people close to me start to lose
their hair
as early as their twenties and it's
always been an obsessing experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 but the best
thing you can do to prevent hair loss
is take the initiative now and do
something about it whilst you've still
got
hair left i really like keeps because it
makes treatment super easy by delivering
your hair loss medication every three
months
so you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in pharmacy checkout
lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trust
them for their hair loss prevention
medication
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose hair just yet
but prevention is key the faster you act
the faster you see results
and the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50 off your first order
as far as carter was concerned it was
proof he was close
but lord carnarvon had asked carter to
join him at high clear castle
to tell him it was over that he would no
longer be financing digs in the valley
of the kings
carter was almost frantic practically
begging carnavan to give him more time
and that show of passion paid off
because carter came away with a deal
one more year if he didn't uncover
anything of note in that time
his funding would be cut and all of his
hard work over the years
would have been for nothing as it turned
out carter wouldn't need anywhere close
to a year
he resumed his search for the tomb of
tutankhamun on november the 1st
1922 and three days later
he found it the team was going over old
ground near the previously discovered
tomb of ramesses the six
when one of carter's men stumbled over a
large piece of rock
being a former archaeological dick site
there was plenty of rubble lying around
but unlike the rest of the loose rocks
this particular chunk
was partially buried beneath sand and
mud it turned out to be the top
of a very long staircase that
disappeared beneath the ground
until it ended abruptly
right at the door of tooting car moons
tomb
carter called for lord carnavan at once
and
when the earl arrived the two men got a
front row seat
at the opening of what was basically the
world's most exciting unit on storage
wars
but unlike storage wars tooting car
moon's tomb wasn't full of
soils mattresses and 80s pornography
no it was packed almost to bursting with
around 5 000
priceless artifacts including a
dismantled chariot
finely carved figurines priceless
jewelry
ancient weapons and one standard issue
egyptian mummy ensconced in no fewer
than
three nested sarcophagi the last of
which
was made of solid gold somewhat
ironically
considering the almost immediate rock
star status tootin car moon enjoyed
around the world
off the back of this rediscovery of his
mummified body
he wasn't actually all that important in
his own time
at least as far as pharaohs go and
whilst he would become
famous for unleashing a curse on the men
who found him
it seems the boy king who was only 19
when he died
may have suffered from a curse all of
his own
a cripplingly small gene pool if you've
watched my video on the dangers of
inbreeding
you'll know making babies with close
family members
is a bad idea and not just because of
the funny looks you'll get at the
hospital
unfortunately for king twos his parents
apparently
hadn't watched my video on inbreeding
because they were siblings
if only they'd subscribe to the channel
anyway
as a result of this rather unfortunate
brother and sister action
tutankhamun was born with a wide range
of both physical and
mental disabilities perhaps that's why
he was pissed off enough to unleash a
deadly curse
when his not-so-eternal slumber was
shattered
three and a half thousand years later
randomly enough
the first life snuffed out by the curse
of tooting car moon
taken on the very day the tomb was
discovered was that of howard carter's
canary
it was stationed in a bird cage hanging
outside his door
and its untimely demise served as an
appropriate warning of the danger that
was about to come
it was a messenger boy who stumbled
across the grizzly scene coiled in on
itself inside carter's birdcage was a
huge cobra
the cage's previous occupant hanging
from its mouth
efforts were made to save the poor bird
but by the time the alarm was raised the
canary had already passed on
to a better place well the cobra small
intestine
it was a creepy event made even creepier
by the all-too-obvious connection to the
recently opened tomb
you see that very same day the team had
found
two statues guarding the entrance to a
still-sealed chamber within the tube
fought to hold the pharaoh sarcophagus
the statues were large and imposing
depicting tutankhamun himself
and each wore a golden crown adorned
with a urease
that's the ancient egyptian symbol of
divine authority
and it just so happens to be in the
shape of a cobra
as far as omens went it was a bad one
but carter and his men were made of
stern stuff after all you don't get a
gravedigging gig in egypt
by being superstitious the group were a
little shaken
but whilst a few whispered about a
possible curse
most were certain it was just an
unfortunate coincidence
and a coincidence it may well have been
but that didn't save lord carnavan it
started with nothing
more than a mosquito bite on the earl's
cheek a few months after the discovery
of the tomb
it was a small wound the kind we've all
experienced on a warm summer's evening
itchy and annoying but no big deal
lord carnarvon probably fought the same
but
when he nicked that very same spot while
shaving
later that evening he opened up the
wound just enough
to let the blood start seeping out and
infection
creep in he was dead from blood
poisoning
within two weeks a little more than four
months after becoming one of the very
first people to step foot inside
tutankhamun's tomb
in another spooky coincidence when the
pharaoh's body was first examined during
an autopsy
six months later a strange lesion just
like an insect bite was found
on its cheek at this point people
started to take notice
at 56 lord carnavan was not a
particularly old man
and his death from what seemed to be a
minor injury
was unsettling those
first whispers of bad omens and curses
that had started after the incident with
the cobra
soon became full-blown rumors of an
ancient and terrible curse
that made headlines in newspapers around
the world
and the deaths just kept on coming in
may 1923
financier george j gold succumbed to the
effects of a fever
he'd contracted whilst in egypt he'd
begun to show symptoms of illness not
long after visiting the newly discovered
tomb
of one tooting car moon a man called
arthur mace was next
dead from arsenic poisoning in 1928
he'd been an important member of
carter's excavation team
carter's secretary died a year after
that smothered in his sleep in a posh
club in mayfair
by an assailant who was never caught
as those connected to carter and the
excavation
continued to drop like flies people
began to speculate
as to just what was behind the deaths
the papers spoke of a written curse
scrawled across the wall of
tutankhamun's tomb
in weathered hieroglyphics death shall
come on swift wings
to him who disturbs the peace of the
king
sir arthur conan doyle author of the
sherlock holmes mysteries
had his own theory suggesting
invisible elemental guards left to
defend the long dead pharaoh
might have been responsible whatever it
was it seems as though carter and his
team
were being targeted by something
so what became of howard carter himself
the man who discovered the tomb in the
first place and ultimately the person
responsible for disturbing the pharaoh's
peace
what terrible fate did the curse have in
store for him
hodgkin's lymphoma which killed him at
the age of 64.
a good 16 years after he first entered
tooting car moon's tomb
hmm okay yeah that does kind of mess
with the whole
curse angle a bit doesn't it and
now i come to think about it he wasn't
the only one to escape the mummy's wrath
by
living to a ripe old age and dying of
natural causes
in fact of the 58 people known to have
been present when the tomb was first
opened
only eight died within the following 12
years
and one study by well-known scourge of
the paranormal
james randy found that those supposedly
struck by the full force of the curse
survived on average for 23 years after
the tomb was discovered
okay so maybe that's because there was
only so much of the curse to go around
a bit like a supernatural version of a
poisoned mouse trap
deadly but it could only take so many
victims before it ran out
that could be it or you know
the whole cursed tomb thing could just
be one gigantic pile of ancient egyptian
camel [ __ ]
just a thought as it turns out
there's actually a pretty
straightforward explanation for the
curse of twosome car moon
one that doesn't require any hocus pocus
threatening hieroglyphics or any of
those invisible elemental sentinels
conan doyle suggested we're guarding the
tomb
although on that last one i must admit i
do kind of love the irony of an author
still famous today for
creating one of the most ruthlessly
logical characters
ever to grace popular culture was
himself
and absolute fruitly anyway before lord
carnavan
sadly passed away he'd been a pretty
astute businessman
he'd sunken a huge amount of cash into
his search for the tomb of tootin car
moon over many years
so when he finally found the damn thing
he wanted to make a little return on his
investment
and the first way to do that was to sign
an exclusive contract with the times
newspaper back in england
for rights to report on the excavation
times journalists were allowed to access
the tomb
and the pictures and articles they
printed had their newspapers flying off
the shelves back home
having been entirely denied access to
the site
the other newspapers had nothing to
print about the remarkable events taking
place in the valley of the kings and so
they did what newspapers always do when
they have nothing
genuine to report on they made something
up
while some egyptian tombs did indeed
have curses
scribbled on their walls and entrance
ways
king toot's tomb wasn't one of them
that apparent curse reported in some
newspapers about
death and swift wings and all of that
nonsense
was simply made up most likely by some
journalist with aspirations of becoming
a horror writer
basically the curse sold papers and so
the press kept hyping it
up every chance they got
after that the whole thing was mostly
just confirmation bias
a few of those involved with the
excavation did indeed
die some in unusual circumstances but
most
didn't take any large event in history
and you'll probably find at least a
handful of those attending
kicked the bucket not long afterwards
lord carnarvons was arguably the only
somewhat unusual death coming as it did
so
soon after the discovery was made
but in reality there was nothing
mysterious about his demise
you see back in 1903 he'd been involved
in a bad
car accident and his health had never
really recovered
in fact the only reason he got
interested in egyptian tombs in the
first place
was thanks to his doctor's advice to
dodge winters in downton
by jetting off some place warm on
account of his poor health
that warm place ended up being egypt
and carnarvon became fascinated by the
local culture
a passion which eventually led to his
patronage of howard carter
carnavan was killed by a mosquito bite
simply because his immune system was
weak to begin with
and he wasn't able to fight off the
ensuing infection
as for the mark they found on the
mummy's face that seemed to correspond
to the bite
it was just a coincidence and besides it
seems nobody could quite remember
whether it was actually on the same
cheek as the bite that did it for lord
carnavan
and since he'd already been dead half a
year when they discovered it
there was no way to actually find out
so could there have been a curse lurking
in the tomb of tutankhamun
well never say never but uh
no absolutely not
but before i go i can tell you about a
real cursed tomb
if you like you know just so you don't
feel shortchanged
this grumpy looking chap is kasamir iv
who was grand duke of lithuania and king
of poland during the 15th century
he died in 1492 the same year columbus
discovered the new world for europe
and he was laid to rest beneath warrell
castle in krakow
where he was to remain undisturbed for
481 years
it was a team of scientists who broke
that piece when they were permitted to
enter the tomb to examine the ancient
king's remains
as well as having a good poke around
they had plans to restore the crypt to
its former glory
but they would never get the chance
because whilst old kasamir may not have
achieved the same fame as a certain
ancient egyptian pharaoh
he really knew how to do a good curse
of the 12 scientists to enter the team
four were dead within the week
and the rest didn't hold out much longer
10 died prematurely in all
and of the two that survived one
suffered serious health problems for the
rest of his life
now that's how you do a cursed tomb
textbook stuff kasamir
although i'm afraid once again the
reality here
probably doesn't quite live up to your
expectations
because whilst kazumi's tomb absolutely
did contain a curse
there was nothing supernatural about it
no
this curse was something scientists
could capture and study
something to which they gave a name and
that name was aspergillus flavis a type
of fungus that produces aflatoxins
which can prove fatal to humans when
inhaled or ingested
the deadly fungus was grown unhindered
in the rotten wood of the king's coffin
for almost 500 years when the scientists
entered the tomb
disturbing the air just enough to
release a cloud of lethal spores all
around them in the process
so remember curses may not really exist
but killer mushrooms certainly do thanks
for watching
thanks again to keeps for sponsoring
this video don't forget to try it out
using the link
below